it's not true so for example
well i can give you an example very
quickly so i worked with women who
worked in high-powered law firms in
canada for about 15 years and they were
as
competent and put together as anybody
you would ever meet and we were trying
to figure out how to further their
careers
and there was a huge debate in canadian
society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the
law firms didn't use these masculine
criteria then perhaps women would do
better but the market sets the damn game
it's like and the market is dominated by
manchester united
it's not the market is dominated by
women they make 80 of the consumer
decisions that's not the case at all
people who stay at home looking after
children by and large they are still
women so they're going out doing the
shopping but that is changing they make
all right
decisions okay so the market is driven
by women not men right okay and if
you're a lawyer they still pay more for
the same
so if it's
she was saying or
um yes she was saying that the consumer
rate is
um
mostly women staying at home blah blah
she was saying it's changing
so since that changing
wouldn't you think that
the
the way things are ran are like
similarly going in that like direction
as well or do you think that if like the
if men jumped up to be more the
consumers that it would just stay the
same
um well i think
so are you saying like that women you
think because women buy more stuff like
that we'll see more women and ceo and
like power positions is that what you're
asking
no so i'm saying that if it
if it changes to where
men are the top consumers
will
the workforce changed like how it's
flopped so like right now men are
dominating and women are the top
consumers if men become the top
consumers would it be like on the flip
side that women start dominating
i don't think so because i i really
think it's just the personality trait
disagreeableness yeah because i can
think of every team i've been on every
captain has been a little bit of a like
a [ __ ] to be honest like for the most
part but it makes them a better leader
yeah and it's a reason like i think i've
like haven't been chosen for captain
positions i'm i'm pretty agreeable i
don't take charge of a situation i think
men are just more like that
but oh my god if men you know what's
crazy women like have so much debt like
women because we make less we spend more
like and i just think our whole society
is like geared towards women and once
you see it you can't unsee it like
everything like that's why they're
getting these plus-sized people in the
media it's for women
that is true because like men like that
men
yeah because i feel like
and we've talked about this on one of
the pre-game shows yeah i feel like
men don't there's a lot of stuff that
women care about that men could just
care less about and the stuff that
they can care less about women care
about more so it's like oh let's gear
that towards them
and
then it just
there's just more things i feel like
women care more about to like consume or
to buy than men do yeah
yeah
sort of goods
that's been proven that men for the you
buy a blue bicycle helmet it's going to
cost less than a pink one anyway we'll
come on to that partly because men are
less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it i
want to ask you
that's true if you flop if you switch
that price they'd be like um excuse me
why is why is the blue helmet more than
the pink one like they're both same
helmets say brand same everything
that is true because there will be some
things i see in the store and i'm like
why is this like this i'm like you know
it's the price i'll just go pay for it
it's what it is
yeah no i agree i agree is it not
desirable to have some of those female
traits you're talking about i'd say
that's a generalization but you've used
the words female traits is it not
desirable to have some of them at the
top of business i mean maybe they
wouldn't predict the banking crisis they
don't predict success in the workplace
the things that predict success in the
workplace are intelligence and
conscientiousness agreeableness
negatively predicts success in the
workplace
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these top
covers
[Music]
yeah
she's killing me
like
she's putting words in his mouth yeah
they say so they're not
those words ever come out of his mouth
but i can
it's it's weird but i like and
understand like what he's saying like if
i'm the top ceo of a company
and
someone is disagreeing with me and i
needed something they're like well i
can't do it like well okay just like get
it done on your own time knowing that i
have a deadline but um
oh it's okay it's okay and like there's
times where i've done that and i'm like
dang
i wonder i wonder why women
like can't be like that in the workforce
and then be able to like separate it
from when they like go into
other realms of their life
so watching this would you say you're
more agreeable or disagreeable i would
say i'm more agreeable with what he has
so do you think when you go to
basketball you can magically become a
disagreeable person
more than like there's the difference
between slightly and a complete
personality change
i've played with you you're pretty nice
to play with i like playing like i like
but you don't you don't yell at anyone
you don't like yeah i get intense but i
don't know
like you can't just change who you are
as a person and it's not a bad thing
like it's gonna make you like a better
mother and a better like like women i
just think we're naturally nurturers
yeah
and we value relationships more than men
do yeah and i don't i don't think it's a
bad thing like i think it's our
superpower like to be able to like
connect with people yeah but
like it just comes at a co everything
comes at a cost
today
wow she's getting red pilled on camera
on camera oh look at me
our traits don't predict success but i
didn't say that intelligence wasn't i
didn't say that intelligence and
conscientiousness well you were saying
one female church is by implication are
not female traits
oh no i mean
if we were going based on intelligence
statistically
women
are
more intelligent than men if that was if
that was what she's trying to say
we if we were going based on that and
the work fit in the workforce and
everything
women would be at the top of the game
sort of no i'm saying like based on like
what she's saying no no do you know what
like how intelligence is distributed so
there's more women in the middle and
there's more men on the extremes
so there's more men that are like idiots
and there's more men's that are geniuses
but women are like more in the middle oh
okay
i think guys you can let me know in the
comments i'm like 80 sure that's right i
swear
so that's what like that
no i've just been like doing this do you
know what i'm saying like i can't expect
you to know this yeah you're you're a
normal person
i'm a blue pillar
but um
but then like you take into
conscientiousness too so it's like
yeah like the stuff he's saying is very
like it gets you thinking because if you
don't know you're going to
either be
on
his side of the spectrum and not change
not want to hear nobody else or going to
be on her side of the spectrum and not
want to hear yeah
i'm right middle
yeah no this is this is what i actually
picked you because i was like oh she's
blue pill but she could listen so like
let's
let's see how she died